all right got a stunning new report
reveal i'm sure you read it over the
weekend report reveals close allies of
former new york governor disgrace
governor andrew cuomo including his top
aide and former cnn anchor brother
allegedly plotted to discredit our very
own janisteen janice became one of the
most outspoken voices pushing to hold uh
governor cuomo accountable after losing
both her in-laws michael and dee to
covet 19 in new york nursing homes
janice joins us now to react janice when
you're reading about a strategy that was
talked about with his chief of staff and
his brother what are your thoughts to
attack you and discredit you not
surprised at all because very early on i
heard from a good source who knows the
family very well to watch my back this
was before you know any of the real
press coverage uh you know the the
hundreds of op-eds i wrote all of the
appearances that i did on on fox news he
told me watch your back and then rich as
a party uh
cuomo's henchman was attacking not only
me but my sister-in-law on twitter
saying get a life call this a death cult
so this was already in motion this is
how these guys react they don't try to
solve anything they just attack the
person that's coming after them and this
was in latitude james's report a
democrat attorney general and we don't
know that yet we don't know if this was
in the report uh
i don't know where these sources are
coming from i do hear chris cuomo was
sending texts to melissa de rosa about
me and i wonder if that was on cnn
letterhead that weather b word is
evidently the weather b word yeah um
listen i i'm not surprised but what i am
doing is i'm issuing foil reports
freedom of information law to find out
if my name or my family's name is in any
of those official documents because i
want to know if there was a smear
campaign against you say you're not
stopping right no of course not i've
come this far i'm going to continue to
hold these people accountable we still
don't know what happened in nursing
homes why the governor put over 9 000
infected patients into nursing homes why
did he cover up those numbers for so
long to sell his 5.2 million book why
was he giving his brother and other
officials free coveted tests when
nursing homes could not get them to save
lives there's a whole bunch of things
that are still under investigation by
the way if you have some time there's
some other democratic governors did some
crazy things with nursing homes too
there were several i know yeah so let's
uh here's what the spokesperson said
about what we just discussed said i have
no knowledge of this ever happening and
you must ask why then did the attorney
general not put anything about her in
the report or ask any of any of the
relevant i already know the answer to
that which is which is the report was
about the sexual harassment not about
nursing homes by the way rich as a party
he was the one that earlier on said well
janisteen is not an a credible source on
anything except maybe the weather
unbelievable uh we reached out to chris
cuomo we had no response yeah no one's
denying anything by the way right very
interesting no response is a response uh
meanwhile yours your uh sister-in-law
was on fox and friends first which is a
very good show and she was talking about
how she's trying to find some good in
this let's listen
last christmas i i started doing this
with another group of women who all lost
their their mothers or dads in the
facilities we got together and we did it
for christmas and it was great um
valentine's was the next holiday and one
of the administrators called me from the
one of the facilities we donated to she
said the best thing was that she heard
laughter coming from the rooms wow and
she said she hadn't heard laughter in
about a year
so once i heard this it just it just it
was like it inspired me to do more
right so to donate to operation gifts
for seniors go to
operationgifforseniors.org
the other stuff makes me so angry this
you know brings me to tears because my
sister-in-law is one of the best people
i've ever met and she's turning her
grief into joy for others that are still
here
exactly and that and this would if
people want to donate to seniors yeah
operation uh
seniors the mickey and d foundation oh
fantastic all right so uh it's not over
i cannot believe the aftermath can you
imagine if he was still in power that i
think about thank goodness thank
goodness they're not right uh it's all a
lot of has to do with you and thank
goodness you did what you did well
thanks for watching
thanks to fox and friends because if it
wasn't for this platform i don't know
that i would be sitting here today well
thanks janice good to see you rather you
do the weather and a happier thing but
you know i adore you right thank you so
much back i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now